hurricane Ian could bring damaging
rainfall to Tampa and low-lying areas in
that part of the country could expect
flooding as well let's bring in Tampa
Fire Rescue Chief and emergency manager
Barbara Tripp she's preparing for
everything as we speak Chief good
morning to you we couldn't come to you
with a crew because roads are closed
people are being told to evacuate what
are conditions like where you are right
now and what's your message to people
who are hoping to ride out the storm and
stay where they are
well right now it's kind of calm we
don't have much wind we do have some
rain kind of of a drizzle but of course
it's a calm afforded storm so we have
prepared and we have made some
evacuation notices to individuals that
send low line areas we have communicated
with the community we have actually
reinforced that evacuation with our law
enforcement going door to door to assist
individuals and individuals who have not
had the opportunity to use so many
resources we definitely made sure
they're available so now even with the
shift of the hurricane we not letting
our guard down of course we're still
ready and prepared so
you know this is the first major
hurricane potentially to hit the Tampa
area even if it does move a little bit
South uh in more than a century and the
last one hit at a time when there were
merely hundreds of thousands of people
living in that area now there are
millions of people in that area how does
that change your level of concern
well level concern because we have a
definitely an increase of population
here so we have increased our resources
throughout the state so regardless of
where hurricane Ian decide to land we
are prepared to help other agencies
other counties with the resources that
we have here in Tampa
Chief as Tony mentioned there are people
that are staying in the area do you have
rescue crews on standby
Chef uh we've worked like three
different shifts so we brought in an
additional shift to help with the
Manpower we have worked with different
partners throughout the city and locally
in the area to bring an additional
um
electricians when I say electrician
electrical service the utility to help
in case of power lines we have probably
about 3 500 individuals that are here
within the city of Tampa
you know I know you have a lot of moving
parts right now what is your biggest
concern as you sit and when people I saw
an interview with somebody from your
town that said I'm a trooper I'm not a
trooper I'm getting out of here
another's saying I'm going nowhere Tony
touched on it briefly but how
frustrating is it for you when people
don't listen to what you say what to do
well it's very frustrating and that's
why we continue to have this media push
out to let individuals know that we have
had many close calls with hurricanes and
some people think oh it's not going to
happen but we stressed to them that once
it gets safe out there emergency help is
not available you know once the wind
obtained like 40 miles per hour sustain
you know emergency Personnel cannot help
you so we urge everyone if you are
listen to the rules you know listen to
the laws if they tell you to evacuate go
with family go with friends and take
care of yourself and your family
all right Barbara Tripp Tampa Fire
Rescue Chief in a busy Command Center
down there we wish you the best thank
you very much thank you